former Trump campaign chairman Paul
Manafort is strongly denying any
connection with WikiLeaks founder Julian
Assange a British newspaper reports mana
Ford had secret meetings with Assange
before his website published emails from
Hillary Clinton's campaign WikiLeaks is
also denying the story Paul Reid is at
the White House Paula is Special Counsel
Robert Muller zeroing in on this idea
that someone from the Trump campaign
interacted with WikiLeaks that's exactly
right and overnight we are getting new
details about exactly how and why the
special counsel is zeroing in on this
question of whether any of the
president's associates had advanced
knowledge of WikiLeaks plan to release
hacked emails during the 2016 campaign
specifically the special counsel is
looking at these email exchanges between
Trump campaign adviser Roger stone and
his associate Jerome Corsi apparently
seeking to try to meet up with WikiLeaks
founder Julian Assange in an effort to
get emails related to Clinton now the
special counsel is also looking at
whether or not these guys coordinated
with WikiLeaks to release a trove of
emails following that infamous Access
Hollywood tape in an effort to help the
president out with that situation now
coursing in stone they have both
adamantly denied any advance knowledge
of these WikiLeaks releases these emails
of course which destabilize the campaign
while it was going on Paulo there's a
lot of twists and turns
stepping back what does this suggest
about the scope of the Muller
investigation and where he is well
gentleman we never know where the
special counsel is this is a man who is
full of secrets and surprises and I
think a lot of folks trying to read the
tea leaves based on what happened with
Manta Ford you really just don't know
because he keeps things so close to the
vest what we do know is right now he has
a problem that he is grappling with
which as many of the witnesses that he
needs him to cooperate with him they
have an incentive not to cooperate
because what's so unique about this case
is there is a possibility of a
presidential pardon and while yesterday
the White House dismissed any talk of
pardons we know that for example Paul
mana for its attorneys talked with the
president's attorneys that's completely
legal but it also sets him up very well
for a pardon if he doesn't want to
cooperate John all right Paula Reid
thanks so much Paula all the right to
remind us that Muller is not one but a
thousand steps ahead of us
never ceases to surprise